[موسيقى]
يشده الجانب السوري من انفلات امني وتغلل
للنفوذ الايرانيه وميليشيات حزب الله وجب
على الاردن تكفي فقبضته الامنيه على حدوده
مع سوريا نرصد برفقه الجيش اي حركه مشبوهه
من الجانب السوري من اقرب نقطه على الحد
الفاصل بين البلدين
عمليات تسلل ومحاولات لتهريب الاسلحه
والمخدرات تصل احيانا لثلاثه عشر عمليه في
اليوم الواحد ويصل عدد عناصر التهريب
احيانا الى 200 شخص للعمليه الواحده
حقيقه ومع هذه الهجمات الشرسه بكمها
ونوعها واهدافها في اغراق العالم
بالمخدرات تغيرت قواعد الاشتباك اطلاق
النار على كل من يقترب من الحدود
وفيما تعد سوريا بؤره لتصنيع المخدرات
تعتبر محافظه درعا الجنوبيه مركز ثقل
لانتاج ماده الكبتاجون باشراف ايراني
وعناصر من حزب الله وتحت رعايه النظام
السوري ممثلا بالفرقه الرابعه نظام يسعى
بحسب مراقبين الى تصدير ازماته الداخليه
للخارج واستغلال نفوذه في ظل عوز وفقر
وجوع الشباب السوري